ah ça suffit maintenant
pour notre dernier jour ensemble j'avais
envie d'être sincère tu vois il y a une
fausse Inès qui me prie trop plaisir
c'est que tu prennes une douche au moins
une fois dans ta vie parce qu'en fait tu
vois je suis là je suis plus là madame
vous êtes là ben non je suis plus là
connard parce que je me casse allez
installer
vous ne partez plus
une enseignante volé votre mutation
c'est moi cette me fait parfaite on
dirait l'abbé Pierre Céline Dion Gandhi
réunion dans le même corps que la
meilleure gagne je fais quoi moi
maintenant vous faites tout comme votre
adversaire mais en mieux
elle a une chorale de petit gâteau vous
montez une association pour illettré
la séduction vous donnez un cours
d'alphabétisation je ne me trompe pas
c'est exactement ça je m'appelle
Elie Kia j'ai décidé de faire une classe
communale avec vous et ma cage pour
adulte c'est pas possible
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce qui rigole maintenant
madame regardez les ploucs
[Musique]